hundreds of miles of british coastline
could soon be underwater
submerged by rising sea levels over the
next 30 years
homes and businesses lost
the seafront setting is the main selling
point of this cafe in western superman
but for the owner it's now the biggest
threat to the future of her business
it's worrying from an insurance point of
view because obviously
i find out harder to get insurance if
waters rise and
also
yeah i mean in sort of 20 30 years time
maybe none of this will be here
it's a reality being faced by owners of
almost 200 000 properties around
england's coasts
the damage caused by climate change
could already have been done
we're being warned that significant sea
level rise by the 2050s is almost
inevitable even if emissions are now cut
rapidly that's because sea levels
respond relatively slowly to changes in
global temperatures
it means homes being built and bought
now could need to be abandoned even
before the mortgage is paid off
people need to start planning for an
uncertain future according to this
latest
research it will always be a case of a
collaboration between the local
communities
the local authority and
national government to think through
exactly where
we can protect and how we protect but
what we're saying here is we really need
to start that conversation because it
takes a long time for things to change
and people need clarity on that
direction of travel and where
it isn't possible to protect the
community we need to
support them
it wasn't something ian and his wife
narissa even thought about when they
retired to somerset to live by the sea
but now they're worried
doubt the house insurance would cover it
it would be our children selling it
because i you know i can't i don't think
it'll be in our lifetime so it will be
our children and i would worry about
that yes
um
i don't know what they could do
all we do know is our coastlines are
changing and that change will have
consequences for people who call these
places home
becky johnson sky news on the north
somerset coast